breaking trail is a common thing for
doing anything during the winter time I
mean you got a break trail to the
outhouse so you got a break trail to the
steam bath when you get big snows like
this you got a break trail wherever
wherever you need to go once you got a
trail set though it makes it traveling a
lot easier first he's gonna scout out
the other side because just because we
can make it up that's when we can make
it back down who knows what the other
side looks like if it's good they'll
come back around put the sled up and
I'll walk up that's because it's easier
on him with me in the low that's a bit
much
so I just I left Martha behind for a
little bit I went back got her brought
her to the base of this hill had to
fight the hill a little bit a little
topography and our way and she's walking
up behind me right now then we're just
gonna keep on keepin on and hopefully
we'll be able to get to this lake with
some decent light left and enjoy a nice
day ice fishin